that's Ransa for salt graph it on a
number line I just did that's it there's
the X number line and that black thing
is the solution now I'm going to make
finally two notes now that answer the
question
have a look at my incident if I just
gave you a question for by itself - did
master your question three
it's very likely because I went I saw
something you did this it's very likely
that you would have drawn something like
this like that or or even like like that
okay with the circle sort of hovering
somewhere and this lines going around
somewhere
now can anyone tell me why I avoid doing
this and I prefer this can anyone see
from the diagram why this is actually I
don't
[Music]
what you reckon was
according to me
yeah yeah exactly right if I write that
um draw that line the horizontal line
that's part of my solution that I've
graph if I draw a vertically up do you
see that actually has meaning that means
something different where you choose to
put that vertically so therefore I don't
want to put it vertically up above I
need to rely on that line it's on the
number line not somewhere in the
vicinity of the number line so drawer
one now I promised I said I would tell
you that would end and where it's useful
won't you come back to this question
underneath it I want you to write a
question is five
okay so all I've done is I've taken
question four and I've reversed the
direction of the inequality okay this is
where the word and comes in if I can't
even do this algebraically you'll do
this just like you did before
typically equality to play two different
way now if you have a look at that in
the first line you compare it to this
the solution is no longer the outside
part is it I don't want the part that's
above four I want the part that's
beneath four so that's like in-between
here do you see it
so if I were to graph that I guess it
would be I guess it would be in between
yeah I don't have another number like to
do so how am I going to write this in
algebra well again going from left to
right I want X to be greater than
negative root three okay
you see there's negative root three I
want to be greater than that yes I'm
going to the right but I also want to be
less than positive root three you see
from here I go to the left okay now what
word - I put it between
I'll talk about that in a second I will
show you how to do that I have to use
and he's whining if I had put more in
there I'll just writers say have it but
don't don't copy it down just so you
have it as an into one Jack you can
compare it tell me think about this what
kinds of numbers are included that
satisfy that green inequality what kinds
of numbers with work you can be this or
alternatively if you like you can be
this let's think of a number like say
does zero satisfy by their visitor
qualities is X greater than to negative
root three it is right and therefore I
don't even care about the other one
because it's for one or the other no big
deal you do one that's fine okay
what about um x equals three does that
satisfy one meter
[Music]
well satisfies this one doesn't it 3 is
greater than negative 3 means positive
it doesn't think so
it also checks out and I don't care
about this one because it's all one is
fine guess what all of the houses of X
satisfy that green line it's not very
useful to us is if we actually want to
restrict the domain that's what we're
talking about okay
so that's why you have to use the word
and alternatively if you're anti word
you can write it as a single inequality
like that okay you can see it goes from
smaller numbers to bigger which is why
the directions of the inequality sign
faces in that direction don't make sense
ok is there any questions yeah you mean
for this one yeah you mean write it like
this
like so yeah the short answer is yes but
I will never write an answer like that
and I will never tell you to do so
here's why if you were to take this and
sort of jam them together this is what
we would get you can see I've reversed
that direction of the equal sign and
chucked it over here okay I don't like
this though because it kind of implies
hey look I've got a single portion of
the number line right X is between this
and this but it's not between businesses
it's actually only out science right so
it's a far more meaningful and clear
away the seder
to actually write two separate
inequalities it also helps you avoid
confusing this with this right I really
may never write them as one set when I
only ever have one interval and that way
I make it